[Musique]
voilà vous connaissez brigitte lahaye
brigitte la haie basse et la femme de
jean luc
jeanteur vous connaissez bronchite la
wii est une actrice une actrice une
actrice de film porno je crois quand
même faut gueuler mais trois fois les
uns et qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui aucune idée aucune idée ça
va pas bien brillant mais je sais pas
trop ça fait plus de télé sa couche plus
j'en sais rien la dénommée soit un
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et aux
sports
non vous plaisantez
pas du tout c'est tombé ce matin vu
comme va la france ça m'étonnerait guère
quoi c'est tout à fait possible si
connaît un sport à votre avis aux sports
au lit ou au lit elle doit y connaître
ils sont les marchés le matin est loin
des poireaux sur les marchés aujourd'hui
vous le saviez
non du tout ça vous étonne vous voyez
pas de sot métier
non mais vous trouvez que c'est la suite
logique de ce qu'elle faisait avant
alors pas du tout parce qu'elle est
toujours dans le port aux barriques
tendu allait rentrer dans les ordres à
les religieuses dans un couvent dans le
lot et elle s'appelle soeur brigitte son
blog en costume de religieuses ou qu'on
sait quel point vous donner encore des
idées
ah oui certainement c'était quand même
une belle femme
c'est une infime sayah port il m'est
arrivé de rêver d'elle même
j'ai déjà palucher regardant le
casse-tête de la haine n'ont jamais nous
vous savez ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui non pas du tout non été
nommé ce matin ministre à la condition
féminine
ob c'est super pourquoi pas après tout
oui c'est une [ __ ]
enfin disons qu'à la fête des films
pornos gays les ministres si vous la
croisez demain vous allez l'appeler
madame la ministre ou vieille [ __ ]
urinant la ministre
une lutte enfin pour ma part un ministre
jean dépit ce matin c'est pas possible
lui ce matin donc c'est pas français à 8
heures avec décennies comme ça n'a pas
concédé ministre maintenant babiller
c'est vrai mais avec tout ce qu'elle a
fait bon s'y tasse à son passé et je
crois pas je pense pas y'a du bois vous
savez les types de façon kiabi boire
même tout et même si elle est devenue
ministre jeudi
si la ccir et des gauches qui a pu voir
qui a vu moi j'attends tes à sa personne
à elle parce que ça subordonne tout un
pack cursus de carrière qui est pas sans
arrière-pensée
ce qui fait que vous êtes une bande de
pornographe et de dégueulasse merci
mister êtes facho merci beaucoup mais
voilà alors se passer
merci infiniment
game chose qui est certaine c'est
anthony qui a été nommé ministre de la
condition féminine ou quoi les gens sont
pas spécialement étonné tu vois comme
quoi notre époque quand même choqué
encore du pain sur la planche il ya du
pain sur la planche riant qu'il le croit
tout ce qui était plus crédible c'est
ministre de l'intérieur mais bon et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou